-Our next guest
is a television host
and "New York Times"
best-selling author.
His latest book,
"I Am Ruth Bader Ginsburg,"
which is part of the highly
popular children's series
"Ordinary People Change
the World," is available now.
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend
Brad Meltzer, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's great to see you again.
-It is good to be back.
-The last time I saw you
was actually on your home turf.
I did a show this summer
in Florida.
You were kind enough --
you and your wife came,
but not everyone
in your family
was enthusiastic
about my appearance.
-I am so glad
you brought this up
because you come
to my hometown...
-Yeah.
-...you do your amazing
comedy show,
you invite me and say,
"Come backstage,"
and I say to my daughter,
"Would you like
to go see Seth Meyers?
He's coming right to town
10 minutes from us."
And she says...
Oh, you actually have the text.
-"Not really. It's okay."
[ Laughter ]
-And now -- this is my daughter
Lila, by the way.
She is 18 years old.
-Yeah.
-This is not like a 5-year-old.
-No.
-This is an 18-year-old.
She says --
And I say,
"What if you can meet him?"
And she says, "Hmm.
But still, it's okay."
Which is --
I actually speak teenager
and "but still it's okay"
is "Screw you, old man."
-Yeah.
-That is how...
-Had the nerve
to show her face.
Was in the dressing room
backstage today.
-The thing that's great --
She she came here tonight,
but the reason she came --
You're leaving out
the best part of the story.
The best part of the story
is that --
Well, I tell you this,
and you're like,
"What is she doing?"
And you came to my house.
-Yeah.
-We had planned
breakfast together.
-Yeah.
-And you came to my house
to confront
my 18-year-old daughter.
[ Laughter ]
-There I am.
I tracked her down
into the kitchen.
-That is -- That is truly --
That is in my --
I love this photo.
This is in my kitchen.
And you are like, "Lila,
where were you last night?
What is so important?"
And she says to you,
"Yeah, I was so busy."
[ Laughter ]
And she is --
How cool --
Like, I would've been --
Like, I would've made an excuse.
I would have lied.
And she's just like,
"No, I wasn't coming."
-Also, who is she
saying "It's okay" to? Me?
-I don't know. Right.
-That's like when some --
in a movie where someone's,
like, choking someone out,
and they're like,
"It's okay. Don't fight it."
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Which, by the way,
you've just described parenting.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Don't fight it.
-Hey, congratulations
on this book.
This is a series of books.
Wonderful.
Read them to my kids
all the time.
You've written about
30 different people.
These are all famous
people we know.
But the one connective tissue
for everybody,
they were regular people who
grew up in normal circumstances,
and they all just set out
to help people.
Is that a fair description
of the series?
-Yeah.
And they follow their passions.
Right? And so for Muhammad Ali,
it's boxing.
For Jim Henson, it's Muppets.
For Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
it's the law.
But it's that ordinary person
in all of us
that ultimately
changes the world.
-And you actually met
a Ruth Bader Ginsburg
when she was still alive,
and you invited her to join you
at one of your
book-release parties?
-Yeah, so --
Well, this is the first hero
we've ever done
where I knew them
before we wrote the book.
And my first novel
was coming out.
Her daughter was one
of my teachers in law school,
so I'm like,
"I'm gonna invite --"
The first book I ever wrote
was called "The Tenth Justice."
There are nine justices
on the court.
I'm like -- And the tenth
justice are the clerks.
I'm going to invite all
the justices to my book party,
because I know Supreme Court
justices love to party.
-Yeah. Of course. Right.
-So...
-Historically, yeah.
-I mean, that's fact.
And so I --
I invite them all, and --
And I don't know
what's going to happen,
but my phone rings, and it's
the day before the book party,
and it's the early days
of cellphones.
And I see on my phone
"Supreme Court."
And I'm like, "Uh-oh."
And so I pick up the phone,
and I hear this little
old lady voice
and she's like, "Hi, Brad.
It's Justice Ginsburg.
I'm just calling
about your party."
And I'm like, "Um, o-okay.
Hi, Justice Ginsburg."
She's like,
"I can't come to your party."
I'm like -- I'm thinking
to myself, "I -- it's okay."
And I tell her,
and I'm very nice to her.
And I'm like, "You know,
it's okay. Don't be silly.
It's okay."
And then I hung up the phone,
and I was like --
I turned to my wife,
and I said,
"Well, now who's gonna D.J.?"
-Yeah.
-And so...
[ Laughter ]
-You probably managed.
You probably managed.
-Yes, I was --
Let's just say Scalia
would've really made it a...
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, Chris Eliopoulos is the
fantastic artist of these books.
It's an incredible combination
of the two of you
working together.
How did this idea
first get birthed,
and did you always know
that you would do it with Chris?
-Yeah, I mean, Chris
is the superstar, right?
I mean, you know how many books
have been written
about Amelia Earhart
or Abraham Lincoln
or Ruth Bader Ginsburg?
Chris is the secret sauce,
and his art style --
You know, if you want kids
to love it,
I want my kids off
their screens, off their phones.
You got to give them
something better to look at.
And Chris's art is breathtaking.
We learned early on with his art
that kids gravitate to these
heroes when they're kids.
So we think of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
as a serious
Supreme Court justice,
but when she's a little kid,
instead of having
a birthday party,
her mother would cancel
her birthday parties,
take her to the local
Jewish orphanage,
and instead give away ice cream
to the local orphans.
Do you know what
would happen in my house
if I canceled
my daughter's birthday party?
Like, she doesn't want
to come to your party?
-No, right.
-I mean...
But what I love in that moment
is you see her as a little girl.
And as a little girl,
she learns how to make change.
You make change
by doing it yourself.
And that's not that
she learns in law school.
She learns that
from her mother.
And I love the fact
that Ruth Bader Ginsburg
uses her life to make change
through the law
and put good into the world
through the law,
and that's all we're doing
with these books.
Chris and I are trying
to put good into the world.
-My kids like it because, uh,
they know that I know you,
and you put a Brad drawing --
or I said,
Chris draws you in every book,
and my kids really like
to look for you.
-I am like the bald
"Where's Waldo?"
-You are the bald --
We needed one.
We needed a bald --
-Who doesn't? I know.
-Yeah. One last thing
I want to ask you about.
You have a new comic project.
Tell us about
what makes this so unique.
-Yeah. So, "Ghost Machine"
is coming out.
Comes out tomorrow.
So, Geoff Johns,
a dear friend of mine,
and some of the best
other writers and artists
in comics have been putting
together this brand-new comic.
Ever since Superman
was sold for $130,
creators have been like,
"I should own my stuff."
So, "Ghost Machine"
starts tomorrow.
It's brand-new characters
by creators who you love,
and you're gonna love --
Creators who you know,
and characters
you're going to love.
But it comes out tomorrow,
and you're going to get --
It's a sampling
of all the new stories,
and you get to see them all.
-All right.
Looking forward to that.
You guys, that's Brad Meltzer.
"I am Ruth Bader Ginsburg"
is on sale now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."